voilà alors vous êtes artiste vous êtes
des bâtisseurs de ruines sur vous passez
votre votre temps à reconstruire des
ruines vous fait de la sculpture
archéologie ou de l'archéologie sculpté
vous définissez comment quand vous
rencontrez quelqu'un pour la première
fois
[Applaudissements]
on est artiste des voyageurs
archéologues architectes vous ça dépend
de l'humeur du moment n'avait pas encore
moi je pense qu'on ait beaucoup on est
vraiment des touristes
considère aussi vraiment comme touristes
mais on reste très longtemps dans les
sites alors qu'un touriste reste cinq
dix minutes très vite sauvaître
passeport il marque et quan par exemple
moi je suis architecte officiellement
officiellement les archéologues
est ce que c'est le pas le fait
finalement détenait tous les deux en
1942 vous êtes nés la même année pendant
la guerre au moment des ruines qui vous
a prédestiné à à passer votre vie à
bâtir des ruines inconsciemment ça dû
jouer enfin je pense pas que ce soit une
raison qui nous est déterminé en mais
c'est évident que enfin on a peut-être
joué toute notre enfance sûreté
et non mais maison mes champs de ruines
non pas vraiment mais c'est sûr que ç'a
joué aussi
on est dans une période aussi qui fait
qu' on a joué aussi à la campagne dans
des beaucoup de fermes abandonnées qui
tombait en ruine c'était donc tout ça
certainement ça moi je vous ai découvert
à la chapelle saint louis la salpêtrière
vous aviez fait un travail qui s'appelle
paysage foudroyé ce poids en parler un
petit peu vous aviez reconstruit comme
ça une ville avec des fusées c'était
tout noir eelv et de l'eau noire il y
avait 1 1
c'est quoi un éclair fichiers dans
l'ouest à une très grande flèche en
bronze qui était tombé dans l'eau comme
ça et puis c'était donc ce paysage qui
se reflétait dans la pénombre et
c'était une légende lettres marché
autour découvrir petit à petit on avait
posé des jumelles de façon à ce que les
subissent mais c'est ça faire des gros
plans énoncés s'appuient ceux perdus
aussi à l'intérieur des rues à
l'intérieur der wien comme nous on peut
le faire quand on va dans un site
mais ce site était finalement une
accumulation de divers sites qu'on avait
plus qu on avait pu voir c'était pas du
tout un paysage existant c'était c'était
une espèce de mer méditerranée la
fiction autour de laquelle on avait
construit des endroits qui prouvaient
rappelé bon un théâtre antique qui
auraient pu être en turquie une voix
d'une voie d'eau avec des colonnades que
tu aurais pu être en près de rome à
notre endroit qui auraient pu être en
sicile enfin on s'était un peu un
souvenir de différents souvenirs de
voyage réunis autour de cet espace vous
avez est influencé par qui par hubert
robert sûrement beaucoup de gens nous
ont demandé mais en fait vous
connaissiez pas content vraiment si ici
on connaissait bien propre bien sûr mais
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
s'il a des airs de rett s'épuisant
domaine je l'attendais j'avais travaillé
vous avez beaucoup les architectes
justement de
comme le doubs le que les architectes
utopistes de barbe bleue sur mes jambes
au cou si par exemple demain matin dans
mon jardin je vais me faire construire
un poirier je parle ensemble comme ça
c'est un coûter cher j'ai pas peut-être
que le gabon n'est venu chez vous et
l'ancien marseillais comme ça des
colonnes grecques cotées en l'air je
sais ça coute combien en gros on peut
pas dire impensable parce que tout est
dans nos projets il s'agit d'un jardin
complet évidemment c'est un objet à
cette école une autoroute non oui
combien ça par exemple si je vais avoir
ma colonne cas c'est comme ça dans la
légalité sans fin de journée
fonctionnait sans fils de jean et les
trans en font 5 m de diamètre
donc c'est déjà une échelle un peu je
peux vous dire ça va sauter avec 32,3
millions oui oui mais de faim oui c'est
énorme je dire ça vient ça a pris six
mois de fabrication avec des
technologies complexes fait dans les
fermes usines ça sert à quoi ce qu'une
définition est ce que l'or sert à
quelque chose c'est qu'on en discute et
peut-être rien mais
je crois je crois pas qu'un artiste
travaille pour servir à quelque chose il
travaille pour parce qu'il a un certain
nombre de pulsions en lui et qui doivent
sortir et qui doivent s'exprimer d'une
manière ou d'une autre et chamailler
vous travaillez c'est à dire moi je
construis parce que je suis architecte
et patrick a commencé à se disputer et
casse tout lui c'est le casseur j'aime
beaucoup ta peut-être qu'un marteau cas
c'est un peu derrière les corrections de
ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus